au ski cube entreprendre et innover sont
les maîtres mots depuis sa création en
2017 l'incubateur a mis en place
plusieurs dispositifs pour accompagner
et soutenir les porteurs de projets
skube est un lieu dédié à
l'entrepreneuriat et à l'innovation il
répond aux attent des entrepreneurs dans
toutes les étapes de la vie d'une
entreprise aussi bien au niveau de la
création que du développement que de la
transmission et on essaie de de les
accompagner sur les thématiques diverses
et variées euh ça peut être sujet de
l'emploi ça peut être sur le sujet du du
financement sur le sujet évidemment de
l'innovation avec notre incubateur et
tout ça dans une logique
d'accompagnement à la fois individuel et
à la fois collectif chaque année le ski
cuube accompagne près d'une vingtaine de
start-up mais pas que en terme de
fréquentation on comptabilise Glob sur
les créateurs d'entreprise environ 700
entreprises que nous avons accompagné
s'ajoute à ça les entreprises elles déjà
en activité on en a environ comptabilisé
sur cette année environ 300 3 300
entrepreneurs qui ont un moment donné eu
un lien avec les services de
l'agglomération et notamment de de de
ski cube en terme d'accompagnement donc
tout confondu on est environ à 1000
dirigeants d'entreprise accompagné pour
aider les entrepreneurs dans la création
et le développement de leur projet le
ski cube propose d'autres offres parmi
elles initiative Sky alors initiative
Sky c'est une association loi 1901 dont
l'objectif est de promouvoir la création
d'entreprise dans la région de de 50 an
en iveline par l'attribution de prêt
d'honneur à des porteurs de projet qui
viennent nous voir nous présenter leur
projet il passe devant un comité qui va
très rapidement évaluer l'intérêt et la
viabilité du projet et qui va ensuite
leur attribuer un prêt qui va entre 5000
et 100000 € créé en 2009 l'association
émane de initiative France qui couvre
l'ensemble du territoire français
aujourd'hui ébergé au ski cube
initiative Sky est plus qu'un simple
outil de financement on a la chance
d'être hébergé au Sky cuube et d'être
énormément aidé par la Communauté
d'Agglomération qui nous met à
disposition du personnel et ces gens
vont pouvoir accueillir les porteirs de
projet travailler avec eux en amont leur
projet leur leur expliquer ben comment
monter un plan de financement comment
travailler leur business plan avant de
leur permettre de passer devant le
comité d'attribution en 2023
l'association a accompagné 37 entreprise
et parmi elles il y a emblématique
garage basé à montinil Bretonneux
l'entreprise a pour projet de restaurer
et réparer des véhicule de collection on
a aussi donc un service de remisage de
véhicules donc qui est directement dans
nos locaux et après on a aussi donc la
partie chicane qui est donc coaching et
stage de pilotage sur circuit mais pour
mettre en place ce projet emblématique
garage avait besoin d'un coup de pouce
on a fait appel à initiative Skype parce
qu'on était dans la recherche de
partenair
dans là où on voulait s'installer nous
on a toujours voulu
s'installer dans la région Ouest
parisienne et plus précisément en fait
dans le dans la région de cvel en faitah
ça nous a tout apporté d'une part pour
le prê d'honneur parce que c'est vrai
que avoir le prêdhonneur bah ça ça a
débloqué un petit peuah tout ce qui
était bancaire tout ce qui était demande
de fond pour point de vue des banques de
prêt de choses comme ça un véritable
levier pour Jordi Jonathan et Quentin
qui n'y connaissait rien à
l'entrepreneuriat on a trouvé chez
skycube bah tout l'accompagnement à la
création de société c'està-dire que ce
soit des sessions avec des intervenant
la création du business plan ou les
choses comme ça c'est toute cette
préparation qui aurait été nettement
plus hasardeuse si jamais on avait pas
eu la chance de de pouvoir avoir le
soutien de de Sky cuube aujourd'hui
labélisé par BBI France le ski cube a
d'autres projets pour l'année 2024
l'incubateur veut notamment promouvoir
l'entrepreneuriat dans des quartiers
prioritaires grâce au positif C
laab